we're delighted to welcome to a studio
Admiral William Jeff Allen former
commander of US Central Command and
currently Robert E will help fellow at
the Center for International Studies at
MIT it's wonderful to have you and to
studio welcome a new film and it's nice
to see you in civvies this time thank
you very much a pleasure to be with you
there's been quite a persistent report
that you had some different view Iraq
than the policy that was adopted and
there was the report that you thought
that this the pace of withdrawal should
be accelerated then made so slow as it
was adopted now are you happy with
President Obama's withdrawal plan well I
think first of all the stories that
circulated in the media in most cases
usually have some element of fact in
some that that's just absolutely not
true or not accurate and it's just the
way things are because people are taking
other people's opinions and comments and
rarely the first person accounts in
terms of the pace of withdrawal the real
issue was then and still is in my
opinion the job that needs to be done
and that is to maintain first back a
couple of years ago to really establish
security and be able to turn
responsibility for the security over to
the Iraqi security forces and so you
always have an element of uncertainty if
we knew all the details and how things
will unfold will be pretty easy to make
decisions but you never do so we were
trying to my opinion shoot for
to estimate the amount of time we take
to have the place in good enough
condition to turn over and at the same
time to be sensitive at least at my
level in some other realities the light
certainly the opinion of the American
people the likelihood or not of the
Congress taking steps on their own to
direct a certain level and pace and all
manner of other things such as the other
requirements we had four forces and
capabilities within the region that I
had a had a balance and so as I looked
at these things I had made up in the
back of my mind kind of an outline of
where I thought we ought to be of course
I wanted to hear General Petraeus and
his team from inside the country and
what they had and and then two way off
in my mind the the imperatives that
would be coming from General Petraeus
would these other factors that I thought
so as I sketched out where I thought we
probably ought to be as we project it
it's coming out to be pretty close in
the main as the rate of which were
written down I had some difference
certainly in total numbers most of that
had to do with the support footprint
that we had a country the number of
combat troops was pretty maybe not easy
to discern but General Petraeus his team
had a pretty good handle on that it was
some of the rest of the footprint that
then added to this aura of large number
of troops and since people were counting
back in those days maybe getting some of
that out would make things a little more
palatable but as things turned out of
course once we really were able to get
security pretty well established number
of casualties came down dramatically
interest waned dramatically and as you
know now just recent poll that where iz
iraq and the priority of things that are
on your mind it's it's not
not at the top or anywhere close to it
so I think things are coming down on a
reasonable fashion you're still shooting
for for some target the number one
objective still maintain security and
try to turn this over in a manner that
makes sense so I think I thought we
reshape well would you agree with of the
critics on the Democratic Party's left
side who are saying that the number of
crude that will be left left
non-combatant troops that we left behind
would be still too high 50,000 there are
two issues I think it mean here and both
of them are are really off the mark
there's a group of folks ooh hmm don't
want any part of it they just want
everybody out right now and the only way
you're going to make them happy is to
have everybody leave tomorrow not not a
great idea particularly where we are
there's another group that either
doesn't understand it doesn't care to
understand or it's just inclined to to
support the idea that we want to have a
long-term relationship with this country
and the process of going from where we
are now to prove something in the future
is going to entail some number of US
personnel to help the Iraqis to get
where they need to go they have a lot of
capabilities right now that we provide
there are a lot of capabilities that we
provide that they don't have very tiny
air force intelligence support things
like that that are really going to be
essential for them to be successful in
the sugars and I mean though that some
of these things have to say in and again
it's very interesting several a couple
years ago we were trying to estimate
where this number would be the number
that I had in my mind and jotted down
was very close to to the not Princeton
vision right now and there's some
factors as you look at things that you
might have to do how many people it
really takes to
to work in a country this large what
kind of support things you need it's the
numbers probably about right again it's
we're still a year out from that now
that number may be adjusted as things
move forward but I think that the the
arguments are this general just we've
had it out of here which has been
persistent for some time now then it's
just not very realistic in case that we
really are what one of the reasonings I
think you when you are good for a
somewhat it's a faster withdrawal was to
focus more attention on Afghanistan
because this has been you're concerned
that Afghanistan was being neglected in
order to maintain this large presence in
Iraq now in the light of what has
happened in Afghanistan what do you see
the u.s. additional US troops are now
going to be deployed in Afghanistan what
are they going to do what would be their
mission first I'd comment on neglected
not not my choice of terms and a lot of
people have used it again there's a
political dimension of this that's been
around for some time we have we were not
able to provide all the things that the
commanders would like that i would have
liked in Afghanistan simply because we
had and I agreed that we had a higher
demand signal I'm for a rack that was
the more burning issue it was the one
that had the largest impact in him on us
and on the region and so then the one
that needed to help more significantly
back a couple of years ago so we did we
had to do if we had the additional
forces it would have been nice to to be
able to send them to Afghanistan and the
number one need on my wish list was for
people to do the training we needed more
folks because the big picture in
security at least from my view has been
get the Afghan security forces trained
to be able to take care of business in
their country they want to do it it'll
be better for us and for the people of
that country if that's what what happens
but this doesn't happen overnight you
can't just wave a wand and
there's very little infrastructure in
place we had to basically start from
scratch and build it so this is a
process that takes time and we could
probably accelerate this a bit if we had
ample numbers of folks of the right
people to do to do the training since
then have been some deterioration
security situation various places in the
country that needs to be addressed and
so there's there's more a little more of
a demand signal now for true so I think
we have to be careful the numbers here
but you know you have been to
Afghanistan many more times than any
other senior military official the
report one gets is that Kabul has become
basically the repair of the Afghan
government rest of the country seventy
percent of the country societies and the
Taliban control our influence if that is
the case how are you going to how was
the winner States or neutral horses are
going to roll this boat is back well
first of all I don't accept that that
vision I find as I look from afar and
I'm not there haven't been for some
months now but it's almost as if we had
if it was just what would despair in
Iraq everything was wrong it was bad now
it's not anymore so now we have to look
and find something else that's wrong and
attend a conference a couple of days ago
which I was struck by the Han ring about
Afghanistan about how old how bad this
isn't that isn't I said I just don't
share that view a lot of things need to
be fixed but the place isn't I think
about to roll over and go belly up
tomorrow there are lots of areas in a
country that are not in a state of
turmoil there are many issues that have
to be addressed and I think that now a
lot of people are certainly paying
attention to it I know within the US
government there's a an effort in
several quarters under way to look at
the things that are at play here and to
try to come up with a better way to
address them given where we are today
one thing I think it's important to
remember certainly was the case of my
experience in Iraq people would hear the
term Iraq and they would immediately
conjure up an
something but given the fact that we've
had quite a number of years of going by
since 2003 in Afghanistan we're back to
two thousand one situation today
compared to last year year before year
before you before significantly
different and to before I think folks
are too too quick to start prescribing
solutions or proclaiming the way things
are I could be appropriate to really
focus on things today as opposed to the
past and there's some trends that are
moving in the right direction some not
so but to get an accurate assessment I
think you need a view of today not
yesterday or yesterday's promise so
there are a lot of issues remember this
is a country first of all it's very
different than Iraq and drawing too many
similarities I think would be a mistake
from the start and we could spend a half
an hour talking about those but no but I
don't you that but there are a lot of
things that this country has going for
it number one the people there are tough
people they've been used to deprivation
they've been used to eking out a living
with minimal resources and and so
they've they've figured out over the
centuries how to how to live in this
kind of environment not saying they like
it but they're used to it but they see
glimmers of things that would be
different than the way they did not
least to which your education they
recognize that the vast majority of
people in fact are in fact littering but
another major factor here as people
constantly talk about the Taliban and
the resurgence of the Taliban it's my
very distinct impression from many
interactions with Afghan ease all over
the country that they don't like the
talent and the majority people have no
desire to go back to anything resembling
Taliban rule they had a todos of this
and they didn't like it they know what
kind of oppression these characters will
fix them so you know there are a lot of
a lot of things that are ascribed at the
Taliban I think you're probably a little
bit of overzealous
painting of a picture to try to fit
somebody's image but but two things one
is the fact that the supply line from
Pakistan to Afghanistan has been
interdicted so often that it is
impairing the ability of the neutral
forces to offer it and secondly the
rising tide of opium production which
has made Afghanistan the world's largest
of Emperor 93% of OPM is produced in
Afghanistan which in turn gives the
resources to the Taliban to buy weapons
so these two how do you resolve this two
issues well the business of supply lines
Afghanistan presents different
challenges than racking it for Iraq we
had effectively a superhighway from
neighboring Kuwait which enabled us to
move very large amounts of material by
land into the country and we had some
other avenues to and numerous air bases
that you could fly high priority cargo
and people in its different
Afghanistan's much more difficult but I
would tell you that from my experience
the level of violence that we had to
endure back in two thousand six or 2007
and moving things on the ground in Iraq
was very high it's nowhere near that in
Afghanistan certainly there interdiction
certainly their problems coming through
the mountain passes from Pakistan it's
not easy to get things in the country
but the the overall level of violence
compared to Iraq and this is again don't
want to draw too many comparisons
because there's so many differences
isn't in the same same ballpark that
said attention has to get paid to it
there were no roads all kinds of things
that are different there were no roads
at all in Afghanistan to speak of prior
to 2002 that's being addressed by the
intership initi it's a phenomenal
benefit to the country we benefit
certainly from having better highways to
move our things but as I have watched
this country developed wherever the
roads have gone in
and just astounding to see the
blossoming of economic activity among
the Afghan people your second point the
business of opium there's nothing new
here this has been the pretty much trade
in stock of the country for centuries it
is by all accounts the number one
economic factor and it's used by not
just the Taliban but by most other folks
in the country one way or another it's
not what we would like to see the
leaders the majority of leaders in the
country recognize this we've had several
not very successful international
efforts to do something about this lots
of chatter but when people actually get
there and see how difficult it is that
it becomes more of a more of a challenge
than people envision it's not going to
be resolved overnight it's an issue
corruptions in issue it's it is all over
this this part of the world there's no
surprise here and it will have to be
addressed by the government and by
others in charge it's not going to
change overnight but I think it's one of
the major issues that we have to have to
take on but you showed that but just to
say because there was a heavy heroin or
cocaine trade means that this is the
reason the Taliban are there and i think
the Taliban and their cohorts are those
other instigators of instability or
certainly taken advantage of this to
fuel their their needs but what I've
seen in the country is very interested
in those provinces where there seems to
be significant progress the thing that
makes a difference has been leadership
whether it's the governor a provincial
council certainly working with a central
government to really address the problem
in those areas where there seems to be
success there's a direct tie to
leadership so finding good leaders
encouraging them supporting them you
know everybody needs to the helping hand
sometimes stronger than others but this
would be a thing to be very
they're other other provinces at a very
very little problem with drugs and some
of its just because it's they're not in
vulnerable areas others because they
have leaders that recognize and they
don't they don't want it in your sling
the southern Thailand in hell it's just
adds up to Helmand Valley that sets the
primer yeah now talk about leadership
one of your first tasks as the commander
Central Command was to go to Pakistan
and dissuade try to dissuade Musharraf
not to declare emergency rule and since
then the country seems to be kind of
imploding politically in the sea
esterday there was an attack on sri
lankan cricket team in Lahore just
appeared to be stealing now what and and
Pakistan has now become the refuse for
the al-qaeda and the latest report is
that the three Taliban groups in
Pakistan are uniting to actually fight
the Americans in Afghanistan then
operate in Pakistan now this creates a
situation which is certainly not very
good for the United States or for
anybody what would be your suggestion
what should the you must do to save
Pakistan there's a lot of work underway
there's not a lot of deep thought I
think required to first won't recognize
the problem they can't separate
Afghanistan from Pakistan and just deal
within the borders the tremendously
significant posturing overlay tribal
overlay between both countries puts a
very interesting dimension into this the
leaders of al-qaeda have been alleged
for quite a few years to be hiding out
in the Sun govern areas the tribal areas
in the Western Pakistan up against the
Afghan were very very tough terrain
without a strong central government in
Afghanistan three years with
the approach in Pakistan being to stay
keep hands off the Fatah system that's
been in place for hundreds of years now
there's essentially no government rule
in this area and so the local tribes
have been done with the they've seen fit
and little interference really from the
outside so this is going to be a
significant challenge to get at this but
recognized that it's a it's really maybe
two countries but essentially the same
problem I think is is the first order of
business second would be that within
Pakistan itself the traditional focus of
the security forces was certainly not on
this internal insurgency in fact it was
on Indian and the history of conflict
between the two countries led to a
mindset that the problem was always in
the East for the packs I don't believe
that's true and I don't believe i
believe the leaders pakistan at least
when I was the ones that I was dealing
with President Musharraf General Kayani
I don't believe they accept that anymore
they think as I do that things have
moved on everything isn't square between
India and Pakistan there's still a long
way to go but clearly the leaders on
both sides have been moving this in a
very positive direction step by step
it's tough because they're people who
are hell-bent on upsetting us and
pushing it back the other way but for
the packs to accept the fact that the
bigger problem in the country is now
this insurgency is a significant mindset
change and that's one thing to the
credit that they do it I think they
recognize it second thing to actually
deal with it is another matter that's
very challenging military changing from
a focus from large-scale land warfare
fixed armies large units more
conventional to one on what you have to
deal with a very difficult elusive
non-traditional
a a symmetrically different challenge is
something that takes time and it takes a
lot of training so this is not gonna
happen overnight I think the theses are
trying to be put in place and one of the
things us can do is of course try to
help these forces this use of drones
inside Pakistan that last things in
September their bins and more than 30
attacks which has of course had some
success in knocking out some the foreign
fighters in Pakistan but it has made us
more unpopular than ever now how do you
resolve this issue of fighting the
leadership of al Qaeda hiding in this
areas without hearting understanding
people I operate under the theory that
you're never going to have all the
people happy all the time no way I think
this is an issue of priorities there is
a grave threat already amply
demonstrated to not just the United
States but Democratic people throughout
the world that emanates from this group
of folks that are hell-bent on on and
posing their vision of the world on the
rest of us if there is intelligence it
seems to me and I think we have to be a
little careful there a lot of things
that have been ascribed to drone attacks
that have maybe not been shall we say
documented by government authorities of
anywhere here but accepting this
generally there's a need from time to
time or I suspect there's a perceived
need and I recognize that I'm not part
of the process anymore that you may have
to act in some circumstances that the
potential for negative activity either
in the region or outside may dictate a
sense of urgency that you need to do
something and trying to keep pressure on
these people is really important we were
buying time I think in several respects
one for the forces the security forces
in Afghanistan to grow confident enough
to really
be aggressive in their in their border
regions same time changing pack
capabilities from one that's focused
again this main battle kind of idea to
one that's going to be effective in
dealing facts have made several forays
back into the these areas with some
success they've paid a high price for it
and so it would seem to me as an outside
observer now that this is an area that
needs a lot of work and it's not going
to happen overnight so meanwhile just
giving people a free free rein and a
little doubt that there are some bad
actors mixed in amongst these tribal
people who have been given support and
shelter for various reasons probably
don't know all the details so I think
you're going to find that we'll probably
see judgments being me regularly here on
just how much pressure of what kind to
try to disrupt the potential for for
very very serious attacks and as the pax
Pakistani people and leadership have
have now discovered it can be very very
hurtful look at the assassinations the
other attempts the other bombings this
tragic thing with the Sri Lankans just
yesterday and so they'll have to deal
with it would be wonderful for all
concerned certainly from our view I
would think and the backs of you if they
could be deal with this stuff themselves
we have a way to go in February 2007 the
u.s. I think char ministration was
proposing to increase the carrier battle
group from two to three in the Gulf and
you are reported to have said no to the
additional third carrier battle group
and the reason for the administration
attempt to increase the battle group
presence there was to basically send a
signal to Iran that they should not
pursue with their nuclear program now if
you did oppose this additional battle
group what would have been your
reasoning well some of these things are
still best left in the realm of things
that maybe we'll talk about in feature
because of
some classification and intelligence
issues but generally as i looked at
decisions within Central Command region
in terms of forces I was I was keen to
because of the cost of doing business
both with Wars ongoing in Afghanistan
and Iraq that when we made a operational
move that we were getting some value
return on our substantial investment I
happen to be one that's very keen to
periodically assemble significant
capabilities for a number of reasons to
demonstrate to ourselves that we have
the ability to operate in the sizes and
and differences in capabilities that
that we don't routinely get to do also
to demonstrate to interested parties or
people who should be interested in the
region both friends and allies that we
have these capabilities that are very
robust and to those who might come up
with bad ideas that we have significant
capability and we are very flexible and
we can move things pretty rapidly and so
it's a judge it's a judgment issue on
timing of intent an ability to pull
together things and so I was again a lot
of this chatter in the media was just
people looking for political
justification for their views but if you
go back and look at the record with me
I've been pretty strong and having a
flexibility did I think we needed things
to be just hanging around no I'm not
wanting to just put people I've spent
too many years too many months and weeks
in my own experience of kind of
twiddling thumbs while somebody tried to
make a decision I like the action part
move them in demonstrate what you need
to do move them out go put them
somewhere else in lots of places demand
signal for aircraft carriers in the
world is unending
and when I was in the Pacific I was
always trying to convince people to move
move some of them and in significant
numbers out there so I think a lot of
this again overblown ngayon but there
are certainly signals to be sent from
time to time and and we have need
periodically to demonstrate our
capabilities your friend Admiral Mullen
has said recently that Iran does have
enough look rich enriched uranium to
actually produce a nuclear device that
being the case how does the United
States of the world community bring Iran
Iran back to compliance with IAEA
probably one of the top issues on the
agenda for this administration and for
other others in the region I think it's
a challenge to deal with these guys for
for many reasons not least of which is
we've had 30 years of basically silence
official silence between them lots of
chatter but but no no dialogue little
doubt in my mind that the Iranians are
pursuing an objective of trying to get
to nuclear weapons capability which is
not going to be good for anybody in the
world that I can see a lot of
motivations for this and we may be part
of the part of the problem but
nonetheless it's been their activity in
pursuit of this goal as well as some
significantly other disruptive
activities that it's really been a
problem it was for me during my tenure
and remains so we have to take these
into consideration it seems to me we
would like some of this activity of saab
we would like the push for nuclear
weapons to to stop we'd like their
activities to destabilize iraq and
afghanistan to stop as well as their use
of surrogates in in lebanon and gaza and
other places really unhelpful I think
the administration right now is trying
to figure out a way to to get in some
kind of a dialogue that makes sense the
idea that we're suddenly some of these
discussions in in the media are
interesting we're going to be at war
we're going to be a piece we're going to
talk we're going to fight this is
nonsense in the business of
international diplomacy and in strategic
military affairs you have an array of
capabilities which you try to use in
proportion that seems appropriate at the
time to get your point across at the end
of the day you'd like to have people
convinced that there are things
behaviors that are their interest as
well as your own that can be helpful to
them in their vision of the future
finding the key to open these boxes with
Iran I think it's going to be a
challenge but I think there's a lot of
help in the region they have been
destabilizing to the point where few of
the neighbors find themselves on their
side and arguing for any of the things
that Iran seems to want to do at the
same time there's some other folks that
have been standing on the sidelines that
I would expect you probably sleep in the
media in the last couple of days that
we'd like to get some other people to
play a hand here so exactly which works
i don't know i would expect that we
would probably pursue several avenues
here simultaneously to see kind of where
the where there might be some movement
and to get them and start playing a role
this can't be in one way is through
streets going to be an eye on the last
question while you are and commander of
the Pacific Command you actually are
good very strongly on you won the case
of starting a military-to-military
dialogue with the Chinese and you will
be I think I'm happy to see that it is
actually happening now with this and the
new administration but given that
Japanese are so concerned about so the
Chinese claims on their territorial
waters etc how far the u.s. can go in
being cooperative dinner the Chinese
without antagonizing the Japanese lots
of frictions and anxieties in Northeast
Asia if we just stay in that in that
part of the world
I pushed to renew or entered ramp up the
level of activity military Millie act
because that was the very obvious
lagging part of the relationship we have
extensive economic commercial political
cultural education you name it other
ties with China milled mills been real
problem and the immediate issue back in
when I was in the Pacific Command can be
traced back to two thousand one with the
collision between the u.s.
reconnaissance aircraft and the Chinese
fighter so things just went 2-0 not in
the best interest again we had 30 years
of non discussion on dialogue with Iran
and I don't we find ourselves in a
pretty both of us in a pretty good hole
now didn't want to get there with the
Chinese but I think we have to
constantly assess where we are we
looking at intentions as best we can
determine based on actions that people
take and and do our best to have real
experience rather than just to make
assumptions based on distant observation
or secondhand reporting of course lots
of people tend to see this as a zero-sum
game so you move closer to China then
you must be going to be distancing
yourself Japan I heard some of this I
was in Japan recently and I picked up
some of the anxiety tried to allay those
concerns and I think secretary Clinton's
recent visit was designed to do that in
part to the relationship between Japan
and China very interesting certainly
lots of friction but John is benefited
immensely from japanese investment and
economic activity in the country there's
a lot of potential to deepen that just
as there is a tremendous additional
benefit they could be could follow from
Taiwan PRC enlargement of their ties
that's moving in a positive direction
today so it's going to be a lot of
concern there is a lot I concern right
now because of
fall out of the economic and financial
crisis everybody's nervous but I think
one of the encouraging things to me is
that so far most of the leaders in the
world recognize how interdependent we
all are and that any actions are going
to have to be well coordinated with
others in the world that's a good sign
it's going to take a lot of work but
from this very traumatic experience of
today it's my hope that we might be able
to learn and take advantage of this
situation which has now leveled some of
the bumps around to move forward
together to find ways in which we can
possibly cooperate to solve some of
these enduring problems at the same time
kind of ease some of the long-standing
tensions but it requires engagement it
requires initiative and hard work
nothing happens by magic well on that
note and well Fallon thank you so much
pleasure be with you thank you thank you